let's start off with you hamster for
this one is JK Rowling a National
Treasure oh yes I think she's done
amazing in terms of the book she's
written but I do disagree with her
vehemently on the issue of transgender
rights okay yes and I do think she's
brief
do you disagree with her on the issue of
transgender rights no I don't disagree
with her you don't disagree that so you
so you back her on that Ash
um I think she's a National Treasure yes
I think she was very brave to speak out
on an issue where many women who had
raised legitimate concerns were
receiving you know quite threatening
Communications so yes she's uh
definitely a national